[Music]  Mundy I'm ready to be his wife it's only  next second week is the bachelor it's  gonna get crazy it's gonna get weird oh  it already is what is she doing she's  Corinne it to win it  dad would be proud even though I was  naked but it's the naked truth I met  Nick jr. Tanner's wedding I haven't  talked to him since that could derail  I've questioned her intentions in her  motives his whole journey you know me  that you guys hooked up and had sex The  Bachelor all new ABC Monday Monday all  ready to be in his wife it's only next  second week is the bachelor it's gonna  get crazy it's gonna get weird  oh it already is what is she doing she's  cool rented to win it dad would be proud  even though I was naked  but it's the naked truth I met Nick at  Judy Tanner's wedding but I haven't  talked to him since that could derail  I've questioned her intentions in her  motives his whole journey you know me  that you guys hooked up and had sex the  bachelor all new ABC Monday  you